so what's to be done to make sure that
we quote unquote have the right
leadership
this takes in my opinion individuals
making good decisions take
responsibility don't pass it off don't
assume somebody else is going to take
care of it we have to actively
learn
educate ourselves educate our children
provide the appropriate values
and standards and we move forward it's
not going to be a straight line it's
going to be up and down the leadership
they deserve so if if you have societies
that are dysfunctional that have lost
any sensitively unkind comment Donald
the U.S didn't deserve Donald Trump
if you have societies that are
fragmented polarized that have lost the
sense of the collective as uh bill was
saying then you have politicians who
turn to politics not because they have a
sense of common good but just out of
sheer ambition and lust for power so
don't be surprised if you have a lot of
mediocrity in a lot of countries it's a
reflection of the decline of societies
the circulation of Elites is necessary
you know Napoleon's decisions in his
first and 10 years in power almost all
genius and and in his second decade in
power almost all bad the British the
British have a saying that after eight
years in power every prime minister goes
mad
um and and so you need circulation but
there is a there's a place
but but there is a problem we have now
which is that you need different skills
to win an election and different skills
to be a responsible leader and many good
many good people don't want to do
politics anymore because it's just
become too nasty maybe we should start
experimenting with something that was
the norm in ancient Athens which was
electing citizens to certain positions
by lot by by
and they turn out to be all right we
could start experimenting at the level
where the United States democracy is
still vibrant at the state level at the
at the municipal level we we should
start experimenting with different forms
of democracy accountability
Mary Beth said about um we've been
talking about the decline of the the
West for a long time
with that title the decline of the West
in 1921 over 100 years ago and I think
one of the themes of that book is is is
relevant and should be born in mind here
we've we talked a lot about values
the value of this uh uh society and so
on
Otto vinegar who publishes this book the
decline of the West what he was
concerned with was that he said the the
Western Spangler sorry Spangler Spangler
published his book he said that the the
reason the West has declined is because
its culture has decayed
and the sign of a decaying culture
according to Spengler is that
the leading figures of the culture are
no longer the musicians the composers
the writers the artists they become the
the the mathematicians the scientists
even the bankers
um and so spengler's argument is that
you know what and I think it's a it's
it's a good point to make in a in a in
an opera house is that
so long as we give due respect to the
creative people in our culture our
culture will remain healthy yes
[Applause]
[Music]